let's talk about a sport that actually
came back this week and seemed to do it
with everyone coming into it healthy and
moving on to Hilton Head from Fort Worth
Texas healthy on behalf of Dick's
Sporting Goods 12-time PGA Tour chant
PGA Tour champion Leonard here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Justin to me
that's pretty appropriate I think you
know what Justin I think what what you
know we're all of the same how old are
you how old are you there you go so I'm
50 we're all of the same age I mean we
all grew up on Looney Tunes so you
totally don't understand what I'm saying
I know
and it seems like baseball is gonna be
like Wiley coyote which jumps off a
cliff all the time but comes back and
dusts itself off we'll just see how that
goes but that's another sport what do
you make of this past weekend Justin
looked like the golf was pretty damn
OnPoint what do you think I thought that
you know to see live golf on television
again you know just a little sense of
normalcy being able to sit on the couch
and turn it on watch the best players in
the world play an iconic menu like
colonial Country Club
I thought the leaderboard was amazing
going into the weekend we had a lot of
drama
even without the fans which was a little
strange you see if I make a big putt and
there's you know almost no reaction but
you know this is where we are right now
I thought the flavors handled it
beautifully the PGA Tour I mean you know
hats off to them there's a lot of things
that had to go well a lot of
preparations and it all seemed to pay
off beautifully it sure did attend you
know a 10-week layoff is quite something
but I guess guys could have gotten out
than just hit balls and you could do
that in your house you could go
somewhere and it's clearer that
everybody kept in stage sharp there's no
doubt about that Justin yeah I think the
guys that maybe live around some other
two more players I think you know South
Florida or up in Jacksonville I think of
you know Dallas Texas Phoenix Arizona
guys were we're in places where guys
lived they're able to congregate they're
able to play against other tour players
I know a number of areas where
even had a couple of like to day or two
day events to kind of get in the process
of putting a score up for two or three
days I know they did that with some of
the guys that live at Sea Island Georgia
they did it down with Dallas so I think
those kind of things help players stay
sharp
during that's our law so was the
University of Texas the last time you
played golf competitively in front of no
fans
I was playing very early on either a
weekend maybe even during the week where
I didn't have many fans but it's pretty
rare for it to happen in front of you
know basically just somebody keeping
your score and maybe somebody there with
the television crew so what do you mean
like when you're beginning your time on
the PGA Tour or you're saying you had
nobody following you I mean there's
always somebody there to give you a golf
clap if you if you're if you make you're
5 foot or something like that Justin you
know there's a couple times when you
make the cut on the number on a Saturday
morning and you're going on at 7:30 by
yourself there may not be anybody out
there other than the marshals and so but
for it to happen like for an entire week
in for it to happen to guys like jordan
Spieth and Rory McIlroy and John rabe
those guys haven't seen that for a very
very long time I bet not I don't know if
you heard Xander Shaw flee after his
round Justin when he was talking to to
Nance on the broadcast saying that the
fans had there been fans that lose and
ahhs about some of his misses might have
pissed him off more is what he said do
you understand that one had there been
that kind of reaction from people and
you know I saw in CBS I mean they're
working you know with with a smaller
crew fewer cameras and you know three of
the analysts were working remotely I
thought they did a great job in
presenting you know golf live golf for
the first time under all of these new
rules and regulations that were under
Justin Leonard professional player for
12 time winner on the PGA Tour here
courtesy of Dick's Sporting Goods would
you have any concern about getting out
there right now what if you were playing
on this current circuit right now Justin
you have would you have any problem
getting out there right now no I would I
mean I have a lot of trust in the PGA
Tour in what they're doing
only work that went into making you know
last week and the return of golf
successful you know the biggest tab they
have they created this bubble with
symbol F over the Flair's the counties
the TV crews volunteers now they've got
to basically move that bubble to Hilton
Head Island South Carolina and so the
guys that didn't play last week they've
got some extra steps as far as their
testing protocols that they need to do
in order to you know gain entry into the
tournament and into you know the golf
course there at Harbour Town but I have
a lot of trust in the PGA Tour J Monahan
and his staff has done has done an
unbelievable job during really strange
and uncertain times you know bringing
golf
back to us in our homes and I think it's
going to help you know the healthiness
of the sport from you know participation
level I think you're going to see a big
increase because of the things that tour
is done in order to get golf on TV and
the fact that it's one of the few sports
we can still play while maintaining a
lot of the social distancing regulations
that are at place Justin Leonard here on
the Rich Eisen show what was your what's
your proudest when from your career
would you say like okay this one that
stands out well I think of the 99 Ryder
Cup and being able to share that
experience with my teammates with our
captain Ben Crenshaw it was on a couple
of times we aired during this these last
three months on Golf Channel and NBC
Sports Network and so it's fun to be
able to live relive it and also fun to
watch it with my family I've got four
kids that had never really
seen it they've seen a picture here and
there but to really be able to walk and
kind of watch with them on on Sunday
what the singles how it all unfolded was
was really a lot of fun well I mean how
intense is then I mean you could see it
and on everyone's faces when there is
one but what what what goes through your
mind when you're when you are on that I
mean you don't want to let down your
your your teammates that the whole
country is also watching there's you
know nothing you know
pisses people off more than a one would
think is somebody some European that
feels they're better than the Americans
you know I don't know where that comes
from but it just it just feel it in the
pit of your stomach certainly when
you're watching and wonder what it's
like when you're playing it you know so
the game of golf it's an individual
sport and you know if if a player misses
applied on any given week outside the
Ryder Cup or Bruns Cup you know the only
there's only a handful of people that
are disappointed you know unless it's
one of the superstars and it got a lot
of fans but even still you know any time
if I missed a putt a regular event you
know yeah my wife would be disappointed
my caddy
you know this map but but it's a very
small amount of people then all of a
sudden you get into the situation of a
Ryder Cup where you know you're playing
for you know peers guys you're trying to
beat every week you're playing for
captain who you've probably admired most
all or some part of your career and then
you're paying playing for either you
know a nation United States or you know
a region in Europe and it's just the
amount of pressure that's why you see
the reaction that you do on a Friday
morning
you see reactions better than you see at
any other Tour event because of the
enormity of the situation the fact that
these players aren't under that much
pressure they're under their own
individual pressure but now into the
flame for something bigger than
themselves and and that's why you see a
lot of that emotion come out you keep
those shirts Justin I still got it
I don't have the Thursday Friday you
know Saturday shirt but I still
that Sunday shirt and it still smells
like stale champagne actually pretty
nice smell considering that we want I
mean you can't get that smell it's 21
years 21 years man that's crazy I mean
it's absolutely insane what are you
doing for Dick's Sporting Goods right
now where are you are you sensing that
people are trying to get back out there
getting fitted for clubs and beginning
to start thinking about playing I know I
know I know my kids we were watching the
golf this week and they're like what you
know let's go hit some balls you know
like to scale those wiffle balls and
start hitting them in the backyard right
it's you know it's really a perfect time
with summer golf courses if they're if
they haven't been open they're starting
to open up Father's Day is around the
corner and my dad's coming up here in a
couple weeks
Nestle with me and I'm gonna go swing by
and pick something up for him you know
it's also a great time to drop hens for
your kids you know they've got all the
technology available and there's a lot
of great things on sale here before
Father's Day and again you can check out
at Dick's calm or golf galaxy calm for
for more information Justin I know you
got to run appreciate the time let's
chat again soon you guys Justin Leonard
right here in the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here